il est le dernier samouraï tom cruise
part à la conquête des écrans français
dans un rôle taillé sur mesure la star
hollywoodienne qui vient de déclencher
l'hystérie à paris lors de sa tournée de
promotion le dernier samouraï est une
épopée guerrière et spirituelle entre
orient et occident
michel vial yvon bodin 1876 dans un
japon partagées entre tradition
illustrée par les samouraïs et modernité
représentés par des politiciens peu
scrupuleux tom cruise incarne un soldat
perdu hanté par le massacre des indiens
auxquels il a participé aéro élégant et
courageux dont les fidélité personnelle
l'emportent sur les contraintes
politiques se racontent l'histoire
l'effet d'un culture à un autre
et ce qui se passe quand on ment
et c'est changer ce qui se passe rien de
moderne car il
quel ancien qui départ alors que
voulez-vous connaître mon élément
blessé et capturé par le dernier chef
d'une longue lignée de guerrier samouraï
le capitaine al green se rachète à ses
propres yeux en prenant fait et cause
pour l'esprit samouraï et son code du
bushido qui prône droiture justice
honneur compassion ac loyauté une épopée
généreuse qui part est atypique dans la
mairie politique de 2004 je pense qu'il
faut y voir un sens plus universel pas
seulement américaine et même mondiale
le petit gibier il s'y livrer d'autres
cultures
je sais qu'une vraie communication des
barrières et supprime ignorance cela
fait partie de la beauté du cinéma et de
la mode depuis la mort de monsieur
kurosawa
mais personne au japon n'a été capable
de réaliser un film comme celui ci est
un cinéaste america la forme c'est
incroyable et les japonais adorent le
film moi je suis fier de l'avoir fait
hommage respectueux au cinéma et au
passé mythique du japon le dernier
samouraï d'edward fiq alterne les
batailles spectaculaires et les scènes
plus intimistes où les sentiments
l'esprit est là grâce composent une
oeuvre peu conventionnelles une oeuvre
magnifique et marquante dans la suite de
danse avec les loups dont les trois
acteurs principaux de japonais et un
américain symbolise les beautés
impérissable de la tradition